we need to do something about the gender pay gap
we must create opportunities
that women can resume their profession um
currently in germany uh
Improve the care situation Education system
there are uh many many construction sites
where you can get along really well
me moves above all equality um
From people with dark skin color
from general
People with culturally diverse backgrounds
I am concerned with equality
from people with LGBTQ background
and um also
From people
ill with mental and physical limitations
we disabled people are very disadvantaged
because we will not enter the 1st labor market
directly integrated
but partly inbehindertenwerkstatten so to speak
updated did you know
what I am currently observing
is just the EuropeanSchwerbehindertenausweis
he is still 1 pilot project
but he will he will lean in where he is running
super accepted Cyprus
Romania Sweden
Belgium these countries are testing it right now and it will be like this
great accepted
because of this
I really wish that it happens very quickly
that the becomes valid in the few years